so we get to ride in an Uber with the
Uber CEO yeah that' be pretty cool do
you get special treatment on the app I
do not get special treatment on the if
we call an electric car right now who
comes first yours or mine it's an Open
Marketplace it depends you never know
who comes in first all right let's do it
let's pick our destination you can see
lots of options you can go Comfort
electric you can go green there's like
10 options here right now more than lot
of options are you at all worried about
overwhelming consumers you know going
green is is going to take some time and
we want to give as many choices to
Consumers so that they can pick to go
green on their terms the way the way
that they want but let's go Comfort
electric since there are two of us in
the car let's do
[Music]
it here's
haey hello Hi how are youing how are you
I'm
good what is Uber's current carbon
footprint it's pretty significant
generally the footprint is is based on
essentially all the miles driven we
completed 2 billion trips to this last
quarter and we've got to do everything
that we can in order to reduce that
footprint and we committed that by 2030
in the US and Europe and Canada we're
going to be all electric and by 2040
we're going to be electric all over the
world that's an ambitious Target Uber
wants to cut emissions entirely so for
this ride haing giant that means getting
to Total electrification which would be
nothing short of a green Miracle it's
all part of the company's sustainability
agenda called go get
zero the goal is to go electric and
create the incentives for drivers to go
electric as quickly as possible and
Riders to pick electric as well so the
smart charging technology is allowing
drivers to know when and where to charge
to feel safe to get routes that are
efficient then on the rider side is
actually a feature for you to see how
much you're saving in terms of emissions
so when you get that green car or when
you get get that Comfort electric will
show you how much you're helping out the
environment how many emissions you're
saving we have to get that fly wheel
together we need drivers to choose
electric and then we're going to put
more and more electric options in front
of consumers as well how much more does
it cost to ride electric if you're
taking green actually it's the same
exact price as an Uber X so are you
taking the hit on that or does the
driver take the hit on that where does
that cost we take the hit so we've we've
said that we are investing $800 million
in the transition to electric and we've
got to make it economically sensible for
drivers so for example our take rate on
electric rides is lower because right
now generally EES cost more than
combustion
[Music]
engines so I asked my driver today my
Uber driver
today if he would switch to electric and
he said absolutely not he said the
Grid's not ready m MH what about the
range anxiety what about the time it
takes to charge when you could be you
could be driving you could be making
money yeah those are real issues and I
do think that as it relates to charging
we're introducing now smart charge and
routing technology how does that work
what it does is when you go out and
start driving based on your earnings
opportunity in city we will identify
smart locations for you to charge we'll
tell you when you should charge cuz even
the charging cost go up and down on a
daily basis or based on different
locations and another really cool
technology that we're introducing is
actually smart routing as well we use AI
algorithms so that if let's say you're
at a 25% charge or a 30% charge we won't
send you on a really long trip but we're
not going to send you on a trip that is
in a charging desert we're going to make
sure that there are plenty of chargers
[Music]
around
time to charge up all right yes it is
does the charge time bother you I mean
and honestly it does yeah um it's
different um it's something to get used
to I don't like waiting too long before
I have to go why did you buy a Tesla the
pricing like with gas right now so
expensive I come from spending $400 a
week to spending 150 a week and that's a
major deal wow especially when it comes
to budgeting do you think Uber's
treating drivers right I think they
should be able to pay a little more I
think the benefits should be better like
what like Health Care pay time off um
just regular benefits that you know
every other job
gets the biggest obstacle is getting all
of these independent parties all of
these companies all of these governments
and then consumers to work together in a
way for single goal which is electric
ification so we're saying hey let's as
Uber we should take a lead in
electrification and in the end it's good
business to go green
right San Francisco still hasn't
recovered from the pandemic what are
Uber levels well when we look at San
Francisco in terms of uber and how it's
come back pre uh pandemic San Francisco
honestly is pretty low on a global basis
in terms of trips we're well above pre-
pandemic level we're going through a
particularly difficult time but uh never
bet against the tech sector and never
bet against San Francisco coming back
well I hope you're right cuz it's my
home
too